[MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is Federico Pistono.
I am the founder
and CEO of Konoz.
It's an online learning
website and platform
where you can learn
anything for free
and support your favorite
YouTube creators.
We have a list of channels,
or creators from YouTube,
and we extract using
the API, the channel ID.
Now, every creator can
have multiple channel IDs,
so they can create
courses based on playlists
that come from any of the
channels that are associated
with their account on Konoz.
And that's just to prove that
you own the content that you
have or that supposedly
you do, because if it's
a playlist coming from
your channel, then
you're stating that
that is your content.
So we get the ID of
the creator on YouTube.
We have the ID of the playlist.
We match them together.
Then from the playlist,
we make an API call
to retrieve a JSON
file that gives us
all the components,
the number of likes,
comments, the video
itself, the thumbnails, so
every information that
we need to populate
the data to create the course.
And now we have more
than 1,000 courses,
so we are managing very
well the first users,
and we are ready to
scale up to a lot more.
Technically, we
use a MEAN stack,
and we do asynchronous
calls for everything.
We use Node.js pretty much
for everything, and Angular
on top of it, which
is also Google.
And we like it.
So we're now testing
how well it scales.
We use Agile ways
of development,
essentially develop new
features every other day
and push them
directly into master
as soon as they are
tested and they work.
So we respond very quickly
to users' feedback.
And that's very
important for us,
especially in this early stage
so we can get the product up
to speed out of
this alpha phase,
so we can get it
ready for prime time.
At Konoz, we just
launched our private alpha
about two weeks
ago, and so far we
have 130 creators
from 25 countries.
So our goal is to get to
about 2,500 creators, so
25% of the top 10,000 creators
of educational content
on YouTube in about 10 languages
by the end of next year.
And so we want to scale
up substantially and have
thousands of creators and
hundreds of thousands,
if not millions, of users
following the courses on Konoz,
so they can have a
better experience
than just by watching randomly
the videos on YouTube.
We love learning.
We think it's a lot of fun.
So we also want to make
sure that it stays free,
and that it's also fair.
So we created a
crowdfunding platform
alongside with the learning
platform for creators,
so they can offer
perks in exchange
for some contributions.
That's our goal-- make
learning free, fair, and fun,
and we are trying to do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]